merci à vous tous pour votre accueil ce
matin et puis merci pour votre
engagement au quotidien dans l'hémicycle
sur le terrain pour porter nos valeurs
nos idées et nos projets alors peut-être
en conclusion de cet échange Royal
proche ou ce que je voudrais partager
avec vous
d'abord
que de chemin parcourus depuis un an
enfin vous vous en souvenez on s'était
retrouvés dans une autre très belle
ville il y a un an beaucoup douté de
notre capacité à agir beaucoup nous
prédisaient le blocage et on peut dire
que certains étaient même en train de
s'organiser pour y parvenir
depuis on a montré qu'on était capable
de trouver des compromis on était
capable de bâtir des majorités pas
toujours avec les mêmes alliés près de
50 textes ont été adoptés et y compris
des réformes difficiles
donc moi ce que je veux partager avec
vous c'est que cette méthode elle marche
nous sommes ni empêchés ni bloqué et
donc on continue
[Applaudissements]
mon deuxième message c'est aussi de dire
que notre action vient d'en parler elle
porte ses fruits donc gardons le cap du
projet du président de la République
la session va s'ouvrir tant quelques
semaines et elle sera l'occasion
d'examiner beaucoup de textes qui
illustrent les priorités de notre action
donc vous avez dit on va démarrer par le
texte pleine emploi je pense que ça
reste un objectif majeur pour nous de se
dire le chômage abaissé de deux points
depuis 2017 on est à 7% mais je pense
qu'on ne va pas se résoudre à rester à
7% notre objectif c'est vraiment le
plein d'emploi et puis je le disais
c'est pas simplement avoir un emploi
c'est aussi avoir un bon emploi et ce
sera l'objet de la conférence sociale on
va continuer vous l'aurez compris à
avancer sur la transition écologique
peut-être dans le programme
parlementaire il y aura la commission
mixte paritaire sur le texte industriel
moi je suis confiant dans notre capacité
à trouver un accord avec le Sénat sur ce
sujet pour qu'on puisse rapidement avoir
ces outils pour accélérer notre
réindustrialisation c'est aussi un point
majeur de les actions depuis 2017 100
000 emplois industriels créés recréés
dans notre pays donc il faut qu'on ait
tous les outils pour avancer sur ces
sujets évidemment dans le champ régalien
on va continuer à agir on a la
commission mixte Paris terre sur les
projets de poche justice on a enfin
depuis 2017 redonner des moyens à notre
justice c'est 40% de moyens
supplémentaires mais on doit aller plus
loin et c'est bien l'objet de ces textes
sur lesquels j'espère qu'on va déboucher
rapidement avec 10 000 postes
supplémentaires pour le ministère de la
Justice évidemment dans ce champ l'ordre
public je j'évoque aussi la régulation
de l'espace numérique portée par
Jean-Noël je pense que c'est un enjeu
majeur on a encore vu dans les émeutes
de juillet la régulation des réseaux
sociaux c'est fondamental le principe du
texte que tu portes cherchant Noël il
est simple tout ce qui est interdit dans
l'espace physique doit être interdite
dans l'espace numérique donc j'ai pas de
doute des députés seront en soutien
enthousiastes sur ce projet et puis bien
sûr il y a le texte immigration donc je
vais pas refaire le débat que vous avez
eu pendant deux heures mais de vous dire
que c'est un sujet préoccupation pour
nos concitoyens il faut qu'on trouve un
chemin sur un texte efficace équilibré
moi j'ai plus confiance dans Gérald
Darmanin pour trouver une majorité à la
fois au Sénat et à l'Assemblée
je vais pas revenir non plus sur les
textes financiers évidemment ça occupe
traditionnellement largement l'automne
Jean-Paul le disait c'est dès la session
extraordinaire la loi de programmation
des finances publiques très
schématiquement un trois idées notre
politique économique elle marche elle
nous permet de mieux résister que nos
voisins dans un conjoncture économique
qui est plus compliqué donc il faut
tenir ce cas pas de housse d'impôts
tenir nos engagements la suppression
totale de la CVAE d'ici la fin du
quinquennat
continuez à investir je pense que ça va
être le défi vous aurez l'occasion de
rentrer dans l'examen du texte on doit
absolument ne pas ralentir notre
investissement dans l'éducation ça veut
dire très concrètement augmenter les
rémunérations de nos enseignants on doit
aussi continuer à investir dans la santé
et c'est par exemple les mesures que
j'ai annonçais récemment pour mieux
reconnaître la pénibilité du travail de
nuit donc on doit continuer
investir sur ses champs on a besoin de
plus de policiers plus de gendarmes plus
de magistrats plus de greffiers et puis
on va mener cette transition écologique
dont on a parlé donc on a besoin
d'investir et dans le même temps
effectivement c'est un budget de
responsabilité il faut tenir notre
trajectoire ce qu'on a annoncé dans
notre programme de stabilité revenir
sous les sous les 3%, baisser notre
dette peut-être et je crois que c'est
peut-être le moment de se le dire
heureusement nous avons mené des
réformes courageuses
je pense que tous ici vous avez pu
mesurer à quel point c'était difficile
mais ces réformes la réforme de
l'assurance chômage la réforme des
retraites c'est 25 milliards d'euros
d'économies en 2027 donc ça nous donne
aussi l'oxygène pour avancer et puis je
le disais on aura assorti des
dispositifs exceptionnels de soutien mis
en place face aux crises dernier message
peut-être et c'est aussi une des
conditions de notre succès nous avons
besoin d'unités je pense que notre
majorité elle est forte de ces trois
composantes vous le modem horizon et
Renaissance et ensemble on forme un bloc
central qui a montré qu'il savait
rassemblé autour de lui qui a montré
qu'il pouvait trouver des majorités avec
les uns et les autres et peut-être j'en
profite chez François pour dire que toi
tu as les précurseurs de ce club central
et tu sais mieux que quiconque que c'est
l'unité en son sein qui permet d'avancer
qui permet de l'emporter donc l'unité ça
ne veut pas dire nier les différences de
sensibilité et effectivement il faut que
les débats puissent avoir lieu et moi
j'y veillerai évidemment que chaque
sensibilité de la majorité soit bien
respectée écoutée et je pense que c'est
aussi important qu'une fois les débats
mener une fois les décisions prises on
avance ensemble unis au service de notre
pays et au service des Français et puis
dernier point pour vous dire
qu'évidemment cette
unité on en aura besoin pour affronter
les défis des prochaines grandes
élections qui s'annoncent devant nous
au-delà des sénatoriales mais donc moi
je pense aux élections européennes en
juin prochain
l'Europe c'est dans notre ADN c'est
quelque chose qui nous rassemble on est
la seule force politique qui est
clairement trop européenne donc il
faudra qu'on porte nos idées avec force
au moment où les populismes nous
menacent partout en Europe donc rappeler
que l'Europe c'est l'Europe qui nous
protège que aussi c'est l'Europe qui
nous permet de poser et vous en avez
parlé hier avec un bouleversement de
l'ordre mondial et puis peut-être dire
aussi que l'Europe c'est des choses très
concrètes des projets très concrets qui
avancent dans chacune de vos
circonscriptions merci à nouveau pour
votre accueil merci pour votre
engagement vous pouvez compter sur moi
je compte sur vous je vous laisse
[Applaudissements]